this movie I mean number one being a
viewer so much fun and I hesitate to
talk too much about it because I want
everyone to experience it like the way
we experienced it it's hard to to get it
I know it's fantastic it man what was it
like working with with Jamie cuz I mean
the tool you on-screen the way that even
Ryan plays your scenes off against each
other is phenomenal oh that's sweet of
you to say
you know Jamie is we've known each other
a long time so this is we weren't we
were friendly but we weren't actual
close friends they didn't like hang out
and text each other we do now but we had
this familiarity and we knew basically
what our characters were and we just
kind of clicked in yeah from the
beginning because we we were we were the
first scene up actually yeah and and the
dynamics of the characters were written
on the page so you know I showed up I
mean we're married
she started bossing me around I went
okay easy of anyone in the cast who do
you think has that that detective
instinct like who would make a good one
Jamie Lee yeah yeah she's she's very
good
I think Daniel does a fantastic job in
this in this movie in that character he
sysm these I think he's wonderful
well not my character but I I would be a
good detective a good mystery solver you
in life in real life yeah yeah do you
have a good instinct for sniffing out a
liar is there like a trick to that you
know usually you don't I I don't try to
find sniff out the liar huh as much as
discover the lie and then let the
natural flow taking take me to its
origin okay so if you do have it you do
have the exact it you know as I don't
want to ruin it for the folks we have
Daniel puts it beautifully in the movie
yes yeah that's all you can say all
right
about the thing in the thing in there
yes we were I was talking about that it
was morning like I don't want to say it
but it's just so beautiful when it comes
out yeah um okay you can't tell us
anything about Nash Bridges coming up
we're writing on the script now and I'm
pretty excited about it it's gonna be
pretty cool yeah yeah it's gonna be
pretty you know this I don't I don't
know that this has ever been done before
where a character in a television cop
show that's specific and tied to a city
like that has been brought back 19 years
later yeah and find out what he's doing
now I must miss no fun to use it for you
to kind of like unravel all that it's
it's been a blast and there's there's
there's all this new technology and
stuff to play around with but back to
knives out yeah the thing that I that I
love about this is that everybody can
see it yeah my whole family all my kids
my grandma my my my you know the moms
the the dads
you know I feel good about recommending
it to everyone and when the family comes
together at Christmas to watch the movie
they don't feel so bad about themselves
cuz well they just walked into this
family yeah it takes the cake oh you
think you're bad look at us thank you